no traffic means no flat tires to repair
and the queue to fill up fuel tanks is
no more these trucks can no longer go to
indian-administered Kashmir because of
worsening relations between India and
Pakistan Mohammed shaquille has to burn
fuel just to look for work these days
shields truck is among the 550
registered vehicles which were allowed
to cross into India that was because of
the intricate trade arrangement which
began in 2008 the barter trade agreement
between Kashmiri is only allowed for
exchange of goods and no payments were
made although small in volume it
provided jobs to thousands of people
along the precarious line of control the
dividing line between India and Pakistan
Shakeel has been driving this truck for
12 years he no longer has the
opportunities for profitable long hauls
and on his vehicle alone but shaquille
and his helper are unemployed i financed
the struck when the trade with India was
flourishing but I'm in dates now now
like the trade the trucks not running
and I can't feed my family these were
the last trucks which crossed into
Pakistan since the attack and Pulwama in
February
Pakistan denied Indian accusations that
it was involved and after India revoked
Kashmiri special status in August the
fifth relations between the
nuclear-armed neighbors have hit rock
bottom
35 trucks used to cross from both sides
of the line of control every day just
this truck stand used to employ about
300 people since the trade has stopped
many people here cannot for two meals a
day
after Cosme is among them he barely
makes $2 a day and his family survives
off the land
mechanically there's nothing to eat or
drink that we can afford the only jobs
here were for laborers loading and
unloading trucks people are desperate
it's a question of survival for hundreds
of families no one cares about us these
children went to see their grandma and
Srinagar for summer holidays jazz Mira's
worried he haven't heard from them since
the Indian government severed Kashmir
from the outside world he's also a
traitor and says he's lost sleep because
of his daughter's not for the hundreds
of thousands of dollars stuck in Kashmir
after trade ended mobile banda internet
on mobile phones off internet and
landlines are blocked there is no
communication traders are also under
extreme difficulty as our money is stuck
on both sides the trade and bus service
only began with the help of the
international community we demand the
same for them now
traders estimate 25,000 Kashmiri have
been affected on both sides and everyone
associated with that trade goes under
more financial burden with each passing
day Osama bin Javed Al Jazeera jacoti
on the line of control
pakistan-administered Kashmir